por primera vez el mundo ha sido capaz
de ver en la envergadura de la
devastación en tonga después de que una
enorme erupción volcánica provocará un
tsunami en la nación insular el pasado
sábado el desastre aplastó edificios y
derribó árboles esta vista de la costa
normalmente pintoresca ahora parece
apocalíptica los habitantes de la isla
dicen que el sonido de la erupción fue
ensordecedor
con la primera explosión se desencadenó
un zumbido en nuestros oídos estaban
zumbando y ni siquiera podíamos oírnos
unos a otros así que todo lo que hicimos
fue pedir a nuestras familias que se
levantaran se prepararán para correr
la ceniza volcánica cubrió las islas
tras la erupción el polvo retrasó en las
labores de ayuda mientras los equipos de
rescate se apresuraban a limpiar el
asfalto del principal aeropuerto de
tonga ahora con la ceniza ya despejada
los primeros vuelos de ayuda de nueva
zelanda y australia aterrizaron con
generadores kits de higiene y equipos de
refugio son los primeros suministros que
llegan a la isla en casi una semana
nueva zelanda también envió un barco de
la marina con 250 mil litros de agua
dulce y equipos de desalinización para
ayudar a prevenir una inminente crisis
de abastecimiento en la isla
uno de los problemas más importantes por
supuesto es el agua en segundo lugar la
comunicación pienso que tendremos que
usar una combinación de teléfonos por
satélite que nos permitan abrir más
líneas de comunicación de wons los
equipos de ayuda extranjera no tendrán
contacto físico con la población de
tonga ya que la isla está actualmente
libre de kobe 19 y las autoridades
quieren que siga siendo así